bonjour que ce soit flambeau merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation sur
arte france discothèque qui rouvre donc
on n'est ce pas une reprise de la vie
nocturne à compter du 13 juin également
au luxembourg et puis réouverture des
boîtes de nuit le 21 juin en
grande-bretagne en france aucune
perspective pas de réouverture encore
acté au 1er juillet votre sentiment
mais pour l'instant on n'a rien d'acté
on n'a aucune perspective d'ouverture
donc voir que l'europe
tout autour de nous et ouvre ça nous
donne un peu espoir nous on doit avoir
une réponse normalement à partir du
caisse de jouer on devrait être plus
plus fixé le gouvernement s'engage à
nous donner une date à partir de ce
moment là donc on patiente on al'espoir
voyant que tu te l'on recouvre que ben
nous on suive le même chemin et quelles
conséquences si la vie nocturne on
reprend dehors des frontières mais pas
dans l'hexagone
c'est simple elle a par exemple en
espagne demande même pas sanitaires pour
ce qui est concerné bizarre les jeunes
ce forum d'accéder partiront de faire la
recette en espagne dans tous les cas et
si nous ne sommes pas ouverts nous
empêcheront pas les jeunes en france de
faire la fête il y aura des fêtes
clandestines qui seront organisées pas
forcément par des gens bien intentionnés
et les jeunes seront livrés à eux mêmes
dans des soirées pas forcément bien
encadrés ou est-ce que vous en êtes dans
vos échanges avec le gouvernement pour
une potentielle ouverture vous avez
évoqué la tête du 15 juin
a priori on aura une réunion avec eux le
ministre utilisée plusieurs
interlocuteurs du gouvernement lequel je
jouais lots sera fixé sur nos os sur
notre avenir
a priori je vous dis bien parce qu'ils
ont déjà reporté la date plusieurs fois
donc on espère vraiment que le 15 juin
tiendront leurs engagements qu'ils nous
donneront une perspective d'ouverture ou
craignent un nouveau repas on le crée un
peu quand même bien sûr bien sûr parce
que l'été dernier ça s'est passé comme
ça on avait l'espoir toujours nous ont
repoussés
donc on ne crée un peu maintenant on a
quand même l'espoir je pense que si
l'état sanitaire nous le permet je pense
je comprends pas on comprendrait pas
pourquoi on en ouvre pas quelle qu elle
disposition est ce que vous vous
attendez si vous attendez par exemple
l'ouverture de vos établissements
notamment en plein air comme l'été
arrive comme on commence à parler d'une
possible levée de des masques à
l'extérieur en tous les cas de manière
territorialisées nous on était prêts
déjà accepté le passé sanitaire de ce
qui permettrait quand même en seraient
les établissements les plus sûrs de
france parce que comme pas sanitaire ça
veut dire qu'on va sauver des gens qui
n'est qu'ils ne qu'on ne serait sûre
qu'ils n'ont pas le coc vide et pourquoi
pas commencer par les clubs extérieurs
où le risque un poids en moins pour le
virus est moins c'est moins dangereux
certains élus locaux vous soutiennent
notamment des maires de station
balnéaire c'est de là que peut venir la
solution est ce que vous êtes en
concertation avec certains élus locaux
mais sur bien sûr mais pour beaucoup de
maires nous soutiennent pour nom capable
maire d'aix en provence nous soutiennent
pour noël ouverture les maires de saint
tropez de la baule beaucoup d'endroits
souhaite que parce que les persos sur le
terrain il voyait très bien que les
jeunes de toute façon vont être livrés à
eux mêmes donc autant me suis
reconstruit un partenaire de l'état
qu'on encadre la fête avec une certaine
traçabilité et que en cas de problème le
risque zéro n'existe pas mais au moins
on ne saurait d'où vient le problème
est ce que il ya des actions qui sont
prévus pour vous faire entendre ou
est-ce que d'autres sont à prévoir plus
tard notamment bell selon selon ce qui
ressort de la dette du du rendez vous du
15 juin avec avec le gouvernement
exactement ce april après lequel joue et
on dira ce que le gouvernement nous
propose d'abord il faut savoir s'ils
nous font des propositions tenable pour
nos établissements et s'ils nous font un
protocole trop drastiques que ça sera
pas la peine d'ouvrir
maintenant on attend et de là on dira ce
que se construit à partir de ce moment
là merci christophe longo d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes le président du collectif des
discothèques en région paca et en corse